[Music]
the diffusion has swept the NFL nobody
knows what's going on anymore the Saints
lose to the one wind Falcons the Jets
upset the Giants the Titans run all over
the Chiefs the Rams put up three
offensive points against Pittsburgh Kirk
Cousins wins in primetime what is going
on Cristian Kirk wins me a profit Oh Mia
Westbrook for the first time ever
watched Sunday games yesterday together
yes my friends have an eel my brother
were there we had a very good time I
love your friends man they're good
people
yes there's a lot of times where you
could kind of come into a group of
friends you're like oh you're there
oddball yeah but they included me
obviously there are Philadelphia Eagles
fans which they have a sauciness now
they were nervous as [ __ ] and they
really let you know why were they
nervous I'm sorry I'm letting the cattle
but why was they are huge Philadelphia
Eagles fans and you just a reminder or
Brian Westbrook who is in the Eagles
Hall of Fame well what did they expect
what did they expect I had a great time
it was great I enjoyed myself they were
they were great they stepped it up good
but I had a list in my pocket
of the prop bets we made let's see how
we did look at that paper that was clean
when you started we had Cristian Kirk
over 59 and a half yards to Jing that's
one
Tyler Boyd over fifty eight and a half
yards to Ching Christian McCaffrey over
a hundred and thirty five and a half
yards barely to Ching and the other side
Austin Hooper over 59 a half got a
touchdown didn't get there okay
Cooper Cup over six and a half catches
you know many catches he had zero ooh
that hurts because he's the Machine for
that I was part of our four o'clock
white boy submarine parlay or cup and
CMC and then the one that really hurt me
the most was Ryan Tannehill over 21 and
a half completions
I mean that dude completed like 12 well
me too
you had a great thought process going
into it you think they'll be down
they're gonna have to throw the football
you told me that my Holmes was gonna
throw for four hundred sixty six hours
and three touchdowns I go well it sounds
like tinel's gonna have to dig and dunk
his way to get [ __ ] back in the game
well what you didn't count on is what
actually happened I know was the run
game Derek Henry and the defensive
touchdown and all the water field goals
it was offensive touchdowns are great
for the game but they're terrible for
office if you want your quarter yeah so
you know typical coin flip day went
three and three not that great my my
bets pre-season though starting to look
good we'll get to all that okay we're
bringing back the cup but for Monday's
Monday cup wrinkle Monday cup that's
what we call him let the segments called
Monday cup but first we need to do what
we always do it's favorite segment mr.
venture capitalist Brian Westbrook let's
go into the dolphin tank
welcome back to Bengal tank we're left
go pitches Brian Westbrook on his NFL
investment ideas this segment used to be
called dolphin tank but we named it that
before Ryan Fitzpatrick turned into
Randall Cunningham 2.0 but watch out
Giants you're dangerously close to
getting this segment named after you
first into the tank let's go is selling
all of his shares of what he claims is
the most overrated team in the NFL
because nothing gets an investor excited
quite like a dumpster fire sale
[Music]
dumpster fire sale put perfectly a giant
you better be careful it could become
Giants tank in a few weeks that's a lot
going on in that Giants football team I
love when I hear story is that the owner
left the building without making eye
contact with anybody well that that's
not good for the head coach and I'll
tell you what they started to have
comments about sitting Saint Juan for
the yes the rest of the year I certainly
should have done that week three all
right so I have a team that right now is
in the playoffs I have a team that right
now is leading their division I have a
team that before the year and throughout
the year have had moments where they've
gone that Super Bowl caliber they are
the team that if you like advanced
metrics according to D VOA but heading
into last week they were the number one
Football Outsiders offense in the whole
NFL and I think that their most
overrated team are you buying this
dumpster fire that's secretly not a
dumpster fire well I know I buying the
team that offensive easily one of the
best in the league yeah was considered
at least considered way entered the
league they entered this season they had
an incredible defense last year okay
what most of their games for them and
they came in and the defense has had
moments of greatness but also moments
were like this week didn't get it done
right okay offensively they're playing
well now or no yes oh and I would say
their quarterback may have played the
best game of his season okay once this
weekend so I'm always going to say no
she are not buying this team is very
overrated the most of the NFL no I don't
like kind of rated teams no okay no who
do you think it is I um my initial
thought was Casey but I don't think it
was Casey because her defense definitely
was and you know I love that team did
that wouldn't be it Green Bay one
yesterday see probably not talking about
that let's talk about Dallas hmm
Dallas Cowboys possibly so guess what
was that this might be the first time
you've forgotten it relations if you're
at home right now give two claps Brian
Westbrook really proud of you
yeah the Cowboys they have played this
is from Edward ur they have played the
Saints without Drew Brees they have
played the Packers without Davante Adams
and the Vikings without Adam Thielen and
they've lost them all yes they are about
to go from one of the easiest schedules
in the NFL to one of the more difficult
and dak played phenomenal look great
yesterday fun no and the play calling at
the end of the game the clock management
the constant refusal from Jason Garrett
to go for it on fourth down I believe
they had four fourth downs in Vikings
territory did not go for it on any of
them to be going up and down the field
at will with dak Prescott and then when
you get down there go and we got to get
the ball to Zeke I know that there were
some people that were looking I believe
was on the athletic about some like 66%
of the time the Cowboys have run it with
Zeke on first down even though it's not
been successful and we saw the first
game of the year it was all dumped offs
and screens yeah it the offensive play
calling is completely regressed do you
buy that like they're tight with the
Eagles now for us the NFC East this is
wild what they had an easy schedule
early on you talked about this last week
there was a bunch of change that
Washington my NZ schedules early on and
those teams that you mentioned they were
easy wins for especially the Dallas
Cowboys but we we talked about at that
point the quarterback getting better and
we saw yesterday that the quarterback
definitely has gotten better he's not
the problem he's anticipating throws
he's he's getting guys open he knows the
matchups he's trying to get so he looks
much better he's not throwing the ball
to the other team the problem was the
one thing that coming into the season
you counted on every single game yeah
the one thing that you said listen
though if I know anything about the
Dallas Cowboys
I know they can do this and that was run
the football that I was going to say
defense to well you know what you're
right you thought they were gonna do it
and I would say Amari Cooper's look
better than he ever has better do you
think dak Prescott looks better than him
no that's about you're getting more out
of jail Randall Cobb is still surviving
like he looks good yesterday by coming
around I don't I don't I'm not gonna put
it on Zeke it does he doesn't seem like
old Zeke to me we still haven't seen it
he doesn't have that he's a solid player
right now but he was hot three issues no
he was great he was the best running
back in the league right now he doesn't
look like he has the same lateral
quickness he looks so I don't know
people it's heavy he just doesn't look
as quick doesn't look as Daryl being
able to get in and out
as explosive and that was makes him
special he finished his runs better than
anyone in the league when he's
completely healthy I'm not saying that
he's not healthy I just wonder how that
impact of having those first couple
weeks off but obviously the hodo
training camp and maybe his legs are a
little bit heavy at this time of the
season the one thing that I would point
to for the Cowboys is that their defense
has a stepped-up they've Kurt cousins
through it will drop back 32 times
yesterday right you only have one set
that's not gonna win football games
I I I'm wondering why I'm not seeing as
much from the linebackers and I'm
starting to realize that I think it's
actually a d-line issue because I don't
think those linebackers are getting
freed out like they were last year
because when they went on that run it
was those two it was Jaylon Smith and
Vander Ashiya going sideline to sideline
well and I have always said that Dallas
had a very underrated to deep at their D
line so I just went back and looked at
their roster from January so this is the
end of last year
Tyrone Crawford as their D tackle is
like their veteran force that has been
there since 2012 and he's not there
right now
he's on the IR they had David Irving who
now is not playing in the NFL with his
obsession I don't I don't want to demean
it the man loves marijuana and he's
trying to get in the business of it but
he was a difference maker wish you still
playing Malik Collins Randy Gregory they
had a little bit more depth than I think
they do now and I think that they have
the michael Bennett's and they have the
Robert Quinn's but I think that those
guys are so much smaller than the other
guys that I mentioned before they're
missing the meat and that's why I was
surprised yesterday where I'm like I
know it's Dalvin cook but in years past
Dallas would have destroyed that
Minnesota offensive line and I thought
yesterday Minnesota destroyed out what
you just pointed out white teams win in
November and December you win in
November and December because of the
guys in the trench those 10 guys that
you keep on your roster on the d-line
it's so simple it's really so simple
can't you run the football and can't you
stop the run and we can go through a
bunch of these games where the team that
we had favorite had the ability to run
the ball we thought and stop the run on
the other side of the football and they
didn't do that and they lost this is a
great
Minnesota ran the ball for 153 yards
yesterday that's exactly what you
thought the Dallas Cowboys were gonna be
run the football and play-action pass
the Cowboys end up with 55 50 yards
rushing and they couldn't get the
play-action pass even though doc had a
really good game they couldn't get the
run game going either now they lost in
the trenches and you can't afford to get
dominated in the trenches with
especially how much they spent to win
their only offensive side of the ball
it's the East is getting one team in you
know the West is looking at two maybe
three got lost the Rams was big you look
at the North they got two yeah I think
that right now Minnesota moves their way
into the six and there's a gap you know
Minnesota right now is seven and three
at the six the team on the outside
looking in is the Rams at five and four
so there's a two-game lead think about
if Dallas wins that game there's six and
three and Minnesota six and four that's
right and it's a whole nother so now
Dallas but I want to give props to
Minnesota you have to get some props in
there to go into a tough place to play
Dallas has a pretty good home record the
fact that this is somewhat of a revenge
game for Zimmer because he was with Bill
Parcells down there but also the fact
that they do this without Adam feeling
and I'm starting to see more out of this
herb Smith kid mom I love the the backup
running back Madison Madison yeah like
that one to byung just phenomenal Kyle
Rudolph had a day that great kept in the
back of the hand
one-handed but the Vikings are the
Vikings are a really solid 11 win team
that's gonna lose the first round of
play this is how I look this is what you
got to think about with the Vikings they
got a great running attack right they
got two receivers especially when
Thielen comes back that can win Kyle
Rudolph is a good player in the inside
their offensive line I think still needs
to be helped just a bit I think their
defense especially the front seven is is
good I think their secondary it has
fallen off a little bit compared to
years in the past the big question was
curtain can Kirk Cousins win in prime
time games that was the big question yes
last night he answered that he played
well two touchdowns there didn't turn
the ball and over that's a good thing
for Kirk Cousins here's the thing they
went into a hostile environment and beat
a very good football team in the Cowboys
and that's a great step in the right
direction for the
the Vikings are now this is from blue
Sun Samurai
the Vikings are now seven and no on turf
at om3 on grass yes I think that [ __ ]
matters does it I've always said it does
here's an interesting thing about Dallas
if you're buying the overrated take
there are only two teams that are
currently in the playoffs so this is the
six in the AFC and the six the NFC that
have a strength of victory so these is
the record of the teams you've beaten
that are below 15 and that is the bill
the bills and the Cowboys the Cowboys
have only beaten they've beaten five
teams that have 12 wins combined
yes yes they have it mean anybody like
firfer comparison Green Bay has beaten
teams with 38 wins tougher schedule yeah
and so that I'm looking at Dallas and
I'm going what was great for the I think
it is great for the birds it was amazing
I'll say that but there's some still
questions for them for our Eagles but
the biggest question of the game was
what do you do at the end of the game
obviously your stud running back hasn't
played well hasn't got as many yards as
you want to if you're Kelly Moore do you
keep the ball in dak who's hot at the
time right now Johnson attacking Amari
you can't go Levin for 154 de-balled I
need him just why not yeah but also
here's the other side to that because
the other side is simple well you know
what do you really trust dak to be great
all game long why don't you give the
ball to your best player that's the
other side especially if Dan didn't
complete that I would ask you who's the
better player right now
dacor Zeke because dak is the one that
is a peripheral MVP candidate and Zeke
were going what the [ __ ] happened in
Cabo
well it takes so I would argue that dak
I would argue that dak is a top-ten
quarterback I would say closer to 9 or
10 but I would also say that we talk
about quarterbacks that are showing
growth its year-on-year yes and so I'm
reaching the point where I'm going hey
is this all residual hate because we
didn't want Tony Romo to get taken out
and like we just haven't addressed that
and like is it because he got Rookie of
the Year and it probably should have
gone to Zeke Ling
are we harboring that and bringing down
dak like Dominic Foxworth I had a brief
conversation where he was like
everybody's too low on dak and when you
really start thinking about it I'm like
what is the kid done wrong he has the
quarterback wins that if he want that he
is statistics o year over year he's
dealt with like very elementary passing
concepts and I don't put that on the
player I put that on the coach he
finally has a weapon in Amari Cooper and
I would say that if you stack up
quarterback wide receiver statistics in
that time span they're likely top five
with the likes of Russell Wilson Tyler
Lockett and and and people of that ilk
dak Prescott has done everything to not
only deserve a big contract but to end
this discussion that Zeke that the
Cowboys are Zeke's team the Cowboys are
Dax team that's what that's what the
that's that didn't feel good yeah yes I
got back he should get paid a lot right
yeah he should get paid a lot same thing
probably is Teddy Bridgewater but that's
the big jack is so much more better than
we'll see we'll see but I think this
when will you talk about that does a
good rant he's able to lead this office
that was a good rant and it's supposed
to be Zeke's team that's the question
that's music that's the thing he's doing
that with it being 16 he's still able to
do it i we've seen how good he's been
he's gotten so much better than a game
manager that he was yesterday he played
well enough to with us and he's the ball
taken out of his Blazers and he has a
little pregame hit well doing the show
with Sims like all he ever [ __ ]
talked about was his hips and and when
when we would go out and throw and you'd
work on the torque that means in my mind
that he's got really good coaches around
because his so is quarterback who was
going out to throw you and Sims likes it
well like I saw you try to catch post a
couple weeks ago that's no good
so are you throw are you getting your
hips ready we're already good ball not
like that what's funny is this when we
did this new video the first like I
don't know an hour of being out there I
couldn't throw a ball five yards it was
like feeding and I was like so
embarrassed and then at the end I
started throwing in sinew was like I got
worried for a little bit but he's like
you can throw it he's up at the
beginning I was worried but it's all
I sometimes I watch these quarterbacks
in the way they throw Sims just kind of
[ __ ] me up because I can see who's an
arm thrower and I can see who doesn't
have good legs and like their face and
opposite direction and the fact that
like I've noticed a lot of quarterbacks
in pregame this year or doing this they
have weight so they're doing this thing
it looks ridiculous please don't know
exactly - yeah and that's like - loosen
the shoulder joints but when you see the
head because he can launch it he could
get a ball now he had some zip on the
football the most important thing all of
those things are important arm strength
all those things are important accuracy
yeah and timing yeah are the most
important thing and he understands much
better how to throw the ball in smaller
windows more importantly even both of
those things yeah he knows what matchup
he wants he understands defense is
better yeah we've seen the progression
of this young man he will get paid
obviously but he's played much better
played well enough to win yesterday all
right let's get back to Bengal tank
slashed off and tank / soon-to-be giant
tank next into the tank let go believes
this quarterback is the clutches in the
NFL and by the way I looked up the word
clutch on dictionary.com
and of the eight definitions listed not
a single one mentioned playing well
during big moments but we're all adults
here I think through context you know
we're talking about a QB who's great in
the fourth quarter not one that's really
good at quote seizing with one's hands
or claws
[Music]
or it could be a small handbag a clutch
should be Daniel Jones just fumbling in
every opportunity yeah clutching to
regain it
so this quarterback already has three
fourth quarter comeback tribes okay was
was one of those drives yesterday one of
those tries is this week kingka this
week he also made history setting an NFL
record with 18 fourth-quarter comebacks
in his first six seasons in the NFL hmm
we love to do this where quickest to 400
catches quickest to 4,000 yards the most
fourth-quarter comebacks in his first
six season and we still have seven weeks
left
I believe this quarterback is the most
clutch quarterback in the NFL Brian
Westbrook are you buying it hmm I'm
gonna just without any thought I'm gonna
say no only because you're not buying
anything
well no been a lot of money yesterday I
guess wait you're telling me that he's
constantly coming back makes me think
that the first couple quarters of the
game his defense his past defense has
been awful this year so he's kind of
been brought into that situation so bad
for early defense I'm gonna say no I'm
gonna stick with knowing this okay who
do you think it is bad first quarter
this is my favorite part is when herring
has come back oh man he just he's had a
lot of fourth-quarter comebacks he had a
season a few years ago where people were
bringing him up in the MVP discussion so
he's a six year he's in a six year yeah
stop look at the teams I mean six year
Ryan Tannehill mmm Derek Carr I was I
was definitely gonna go Derek raucous
this segment is brought to you by the
Raiders fans they have been hearing your
[ __ ] all year long and now they're
here to stomp on your graves because
they're five and four they're a half a
game back in the AFC West they've had a
few home games and their dust in people
and I love it was there in the position
where it's great
a wild card right okay so they're second
in a second wild card currently aren't
they they are in the seven seats so if
you were to look at the wild cards right
now Pittsburgh and Pittsburgh Oakland
and Indy are all knotted up at five and
four but Pittsburgh via via tie breakers
currently sits at the six which is wild
yes because listen that's beginning to
see you or Owen - I said they so
champion win and none of it's all
Rollins let's knock it off first I want
to give raiders their love but the fact
that the Raiders and the Steelers are
back in it those two franchise yes
incredible well I think that generators
was building something all along we
talked about we talked to Abrams about
it just the thought process yes the
mindset of that football team it was us
against the world nobody believes in us
but the coach had a plan he got a bunch
of young kids out there playing well
your quarterbacks playing better than he
did before we broke his leg years ago or
injured his leg years ago you got a runt
young running back to her car that back
yeah you mean you got it you got a bunch
of stuff on that offense now that can
score points I will say one thing still
don't have a pass rush here's what's so
great about the Raiders next week you
know they play who's that the Bengals
make it six and four in you know they
play after that the Jets so the
schedules getting easier they could be
seven and four prayin Westbrook heading
into a monster one o'clock matchup with
the Kansas City Chiefs this is a glad
[ __ ] it God's a great matchup with
obviously the old whammy games arose it
maybe if Derek can run can run all those
yards of the chance right up the gut you
want to get on the Raiders bandwagon
right now I'm Jeff and here's a famine
or they could all come crumbling down
but let's be like the first real people
let's like let's say something really
ridiculous
so that like the Raiders fans are like
these are our [ __ ] guys how many
games did they won in a row 3 to 2 they
the Lions
yes they dropped 31 on that team and
they beat the chargers with the comeback
at the ends and they'll then though win
the next two yeah and there's seven and
four we could say right now I'm ready
let's do okay we got to double though
because we both want to be the Raiders
guys a double double shot double shot
okay Westbrook I don't know man I think
we might have to be big-time Raider
supporters I feel a run coming on what
are you seeing
I love the way that they have the
ability to run the football yep they
could stop the run in their young
quarterback no not young yeah their cars
playing with insanely inclined plane
well clutch court they're gonna win next
week they're gonna win the week after
that they're gonna be seven and four and
then they're going to Kansas City are
you willing to say they beat the Chiefs
you know I love Andy Reed but this is
one weakness for the Kansas City Chiefs
is stopping the run yeah Josh Jacobs
downhill football I'm taking the Oakland
Raiders the Raiders will be more heard
of here first
oh okay that felt good that's what we'll
do is we're gonna clip that and we're
gonna spread it on the Internet yes
Raider Nation right and I'm gonna be a
Raiders podcast the Raiders beat the
Eagles in the 1980 Super Bowl so
technically like in it I still hate that
you don't I was negative six
yeah I was born but I wasn't happy yeah
you weren't born an Eagles fan
no you're born in our words but the
player the playoffs overall in the AFC
you look at it look men like here come
the Ravens we'll talk about them a
little bit later Houston still right
there at six and three sitting atop the
eight and one Patriots just the fact I
like forgot they're hating one you don't
need you I just well they didn't play
this week so they buy the Patriots have
a tough schedule and we thought that the
Ravens I mean a Raiders schedule the
painters have a tough schedule a out of
them so I'm a little bit thinking that
they're gonna fall back to the pack just
a little bit still be the probably the
best team in the AFC but I would be
concerned about if I'm from the Patriots
I'm thinking about the Houston Texans
yeah shrinking I think your Kansas City
they probably lose another couple games
they can't win when they're clearly
thinking a Baltimore no doubt about it
Baltimore obviously bills are they're
done the Steelers have surprised me this
was together this week is wild just
because if you look at the bottom half
of the playoffs on both sides AFC
Buffalo now we're going on us that was
shaky also props to Vegas the number one
question that I got what from everyone
all week is how
are the Browns a three-point favorite
against a six and two bills team and not
only do they win they win by exactly
three points like Vegas
whatever Almanac you have they're
smarter than us that's what you Marty
McFly the [ __ ] out of us but you look
like Pittsburgh is now there Oakland is
now there indeed two straight losses
having to play with Brian Hoyer they
fall back Tennessee they get a win
they're still in it
Jacksonville is one game back from Indy
yeah and Nick Foles is coming back yes
like Oh bdn is back in the building like
Jaguars could make a run Chargers are
that annoying team at four and six that
you don't know if they can put some
together I would say some trouble [ __ ]
the Browns still have a chance if the
Browns on Thursday night beat the
Steelers they are now four and six and
the Steelers are five and five they're
one game back how do the brands browns
handle success of winning that one game
I mean how do they do it
I mean there's been some question marks
in the locker room head coaching wise
yeah decision-making how do they handle
they're a little bit small amount of
success of winning that one game yeah
how did it on a short week - so think
about that that's what I'm thinking
about what I'm thinking about the
Cleveland Browns you win and you lose
how do you handle it I'm not so sure
that they handle it well I it will be
interesting they are they're your
typical hope is speaking to Pittsburgh's
playing well they're playing we'll all
offensively Andy fifth at you kids on
the defensive side of the ball that are
flying around their defense I heard the
guys on the around the NFL podcast
talking about it today how many
turnovers they have faced excuse me
forced these last few games I'm just
gonna pick it up because that's the sign
that I look into it a defense is
disrupting the quarterback and also
causing Turnham up more game
that is what up left go it's a pat pat I
know you thought the Patriots were on a
bye this week and that they just spent
the weekend hobnobbing in Copley Place
and going to the I rated hypnotist in
Quincy Market and getting a jump on
their holiday shopping at the South
Shore Plaza but you would be wicked
wrong my dude you see Belichick does not
believe in buy weeks no he was out there
scheming and plotting like it was
friggin Ocean's eleven but instead of
one of those lame-ass Las Vegas casinos
instead it was one of those awesome
blackjack badges that used to leave out
of Swampscott before they got shut down
due to a rash of food poisoning from
some bad lobster thanks friggin OSHA
anyway
Belichick made some calls and wouldn't
you know it the bills lost the Chiefs
lost and we got Lamar Jackson getting
high off that sweet seductive Cincinnati
hubris bro and we live in got former
Patriots legend Brian Hoya to throw
three picks so everyone would know that
Patriots uber legend Jacoby Burr said
truly is the greatest Colts quarterback
since Jeff friggin George I do not
acknowledge the Peyton Manning era what
coasts into the one seat and plus I just
got into the Guinness Book of World
Records by watching Mystic River 287
times in a row a bye week well spent
remember it's not Stefan Gill less it's
Stephon Gilmore
man-ho Trevor's okay pat pat pat but you
better call Gronkowski a lot of people
have been asking is he coming back when
we'll be back I don't even want it
there's no way
how could he but that also kind of tell
you where the team is that when they're
saying well let's get a retire got us
lost 50 pounds after he's retired try to
bring him back to help us that got
offensive style that brings up a good
point it's always like Eagles and
Patriots had the bye
and they had two of the best weeks that
you can ask for was great like Eagles
got the Cowboys to lose a few other
teams got beaten up Rams suffered a
really tough loss and now like the
Eagles are kind of right around there
Patriots he's absolutely right like
Kansas City losing it puts the gap
between the Patriots and everybody else
that much bigger to get another bye you
know there is nothing more consistent
than the Patriots with a bye in the
playoffs might not be the one or that it
might not be necessarily the one
but it's looking more and more that
they're gonna get a bye and big week for
the Pats but that's a huge week against
the team that obviously coming off the
bye yeah it has been running the ball
consistently oh yeah the last couple we
were talking about this yesterday we're
not excited for the Eagles Patriots not
as I'm excited for it I'm nervous
are you I mean you should be nervous
obviously the season yeah we're gonna
get all excited now that we're like time
for the NFC East and then we're playing
Belichick awful loss off a bye they
didn't stop the run very good and I know
it's Baltimore it's a lot of different
things to look at 210 yards for the
Ravens last time they played the Eagles
want to run the football and you know
what
last time Doug Peterson had extra time
to prepare for Belichick he stomped his
ass in a [ __ ] Super Bowl back pad
well I regret doing that immediately I'm
sorry we haven't you got a look at the
Patriots schedule we and we look at it
everything no Eagles Cowboys seconds two
out of three whence dak Watson the
yellow Jeeves obviously the Bengals
bills oh that's that's the exciting part
about if you're a Patriots fan is if
you're a Patriots fan you know that
you're gonna get a bye you know that
you're gonna figure it out and that
whether Gronk comes back or not he's not
balichek is gonna figure this out and
you will experience joy but the other
good thing too is like you're gonna get
tested defensively for the next four
weeks and like you need that [ __ ]
because the Patriots always have a part
of the season where they kind of get
smacked in the mouth a little bit the
doubters come in it's become a meme we
do it every year but that's also where
Bella check all the flaws get brought
out and then he can fix them he turns it
like Belichick
I feel like gets annoyed when he beats a
team too much because he's like show me
my issues so that I can go in the lab
and become stronger he's black panther
he's done that he's done that more more
often than not
belcheck is never the question is
offensively this year is different can
they make up for the loss obviously
Gronk
I think Mohamed Sanu pick up his call
are huge because he is a baller but can
they make up for that deficit and what's
up with the run game did I still run the
football
Sony Michele's getting more action than
I think people they love James where has
he been
yeah I kind of been waiting for
something to Michelle to have these
break a big thing for the Patriots no
one's talking about is there maybe gonna
get Isaiah win back yards left tackle
that's gonna be the game changer we
more Bengal dolphin jaian Bengal tank
Bengal tank they stalee into the tank
left go knows that football is a team
sport but there is one particular player
that we should all be raving about as
the best in the game teams should really
give the ball to more players like him
because his doubters are laying our
Jackson who is this mystery man find out
now all right I think this guy's the
best player in the NFL okay is that it
yeah he asked me whatever questions you
want okay is he an offensive player yes
yes okay is he a quarterback he is okay
does he play for Baltimore I can't give
you a little bit there all right
so offensive player definitely you think
that's like he's a quarterback yep so
he's not Lamar Jackson is he did he play
played yesterday yes okay are you gonna
buy it first before you guess well how
much does he cost Oh
twenty-one point eight million dollars
that's the dev cap of Brandon cooks it's
not Brandon cook
okay he's the best in the league you
yeah I'll buy him for 21 yeah okay
it's Lamar Jackson okay that was the
first time that was the first time where
David made it really obvious and it was
actually yeah it was Lee lame Marv
Jackson's this mystery player nice job
you watched him yesterday we watched him
together we just we just in awe like
what else can even tell you Terry
anything that he can not do for break
down the fourth wall homies and 33% we
were just sitting there and every time
he made a play we just looked each other
like he's so [ __ ] good okay like
Lamar is so good that you feel the need
to touch people that you like after he
does stuff we're just like you're like
hitting your friend and you're like
isn't he no we were touching the
neighbors and Ed was sitting next to him
at you did you see that yeah like we
would be really yelling at people that
may have been watching a different game
later stop watching dharna last look at
this play it was and and that was his
spin move was as they'd like to say in
college football his Heisman moment yeah
that is the clip that whenever ESPN does
their hit with Edward
you're gonna get that 15 second of him
spinning and Nick vigil soul leaving his
body as he tumbled to the earth the best
thing about Lamar Jackson and all those
things are great runs of football well
obviously the offense with Gregg on him
is doing a lot of different things the
most important thing for Lamar Jackson
is that he's not taking these big hits
he's not taking them and as a running
back I understand it because if I'm 510
205 pounds if I take the big hit my
season's over
Lamar Jackson has done a great job of
avoiding the big heat big hit that's
what it allows this thing to go that's
what allows us to have confidence to say
you know what we see some longevity in
the way that he's plays because he
doesn't take those big hits defenses are
so concerned who's trying to catch him
they're not even thinking about how to
tackle they're just trying to get close
to him they're not thinking about the
big hit on Lamar Jackson that's the
difference that's the difference in the
game
what's first of all you can't figure out
what's going on with the ball handling
Greg Romo has done a great job acing you
can't figure out who called in the first
quarter an option in which Lamar Jackson
pitched it to rg3 they say that when
you're so prepared in the moment it's
easy it is easy for the Ravens right now
that was I say you know their identity
so well that they can do whatever the
[ __ ] they want it's all clicking you
want Mark Andrews on a lap we got you
yeah you want Gus Edwards coming in the
third quarter stomping yeah we got you
you want to sack fumble for a touchdown
we got you you want Marcus Peters with
as third pick six this season looking
beautiful in that Ravens jersey that's
we got you that's the best pick up they
got Jimmy Smith back getting Marcus
people that changes the game a licking
changes the game but that I love that
rg3 play there that's setting something
up for later they're gonna run you
something they are throws and III of
course well they're saving it for when
they play the Patriots in the AFC
Championship game in Baltimore because
you heard it here preseason the Ravens
are getting the one see here's the
Ravens and Raiders podcast that's what
we are here's the great thing that burns
here's a hard thing about the Ravens
they give you so much to look at
you can't possibly prepare for that in
six days
ya just can't I want to play you
something I don't know if you've seen
this yet I'm gonna play on my phone
audio is gonna be fine
if you want to watch the video it's
it's just John Harbaugh and Lamar
Jackson on the bench it's on the Ravens
Twitter feed I all not even exaggerating
I almost cried all the ones race ah
don't cry
but John Robie one of these guys that
doesn't let me show my emotions John
higher but I'm going to the best speech
did you watch this yeah I have not
watched it I had a lot of his speeches
yes this is John Harbaugh with Lamar
Jackson on the sidelines during the
Cincinnati game volume is up playing
well it started
most quarterback worries Bob I'll read
it most quarterbacks worry about stats
I'm worried about my team coach
[Applause]
oh good so the audio quality sucked but
I would I would recommend go watching it
the up and back of horrible being so
appreciative and Lamar being so focused
yeah that every answer is like the
answer you write in a script for your
quarterback to say like the fact that he
goes do you know how many kids are gonna
be wearing eight jerseys and he says I'm
trying to get to the Super Bowl
like I don't like and then I'll say this
you what I don't like it
hold on let me finish this I saw a clip
from the draft where Lamar Jackson got
drafted and the first thing he was like
so motivated that he went 32nd he's like
I'm winning a Super Bowl I have such a
love affair right now for Lamar Jackson
that I will admit here I deemed him
today I don't think he got a response
she just told him I was proud of him
because you could do that on Instagram
I'm just letting all the Indian make
love with this Ravens team I am in love
with Lamar Jackson they have done
everything right I believe that that the
original Harbaugh the one that was like
an incredible coach at Western Kentucky
gave birth to two kids that if you
wanted to study them in a laboratory you
couldn't find people that are more
different than these two right
Harbaugh that's in Michigan I have heard
is on insufferable I don't think he's
that good of a coach he crumbles in big
games this horrible John and his
relationship with Lamar
it is like the father-son relationship
that I love that's why I cry I hate I
hate it you know why I hate it cuz I
don't like that type of talk in the
middle of games yeah but when you're up
like 30 on the Bengals yeah that's cool
and that's what he made sure can we come
over here camera I'm but it tell
something emotional you think it was all
wait what type of conversation is that I
guess I guess the thing is I love you
but you're doing so great you're it's
racing the kids that's not a
conversation for middle of football
games but you know what the reason I
loved it is not because of what Harbaugh
said but ladies I love it is because
Lamar is like he's like man all I love
y'all like I got it
I just I love his demeanor the reason
why I love Lamar is because yesterday he
had a pair of the oh yeah I don't they
look like blue blockers but they weren't
blue-black it looked like the Oakley
glasses yeah they look like something an
optometrist here works too much and they
would they'll involve Joseph I felt like
we're the same when he had that formal
returning Eagles last year so you think
that Harbaugh staged that whole thing I
think John Harbaugh again gives the best
speeches I think he's a great motivator
it does he did that for our special
teams for a long time number one special
teams in the league for a long time
and I also think that he understands
there's nothing wrong with that I just
don't like it on the sidelines right
John Harbaugh
is so savvy that when there were rumors
that they might let him go last year he
was like all right well can we get out
yeah I'll go somewhere else that's right
and most coaches would be like I don't
want to talk about this we're not making
any changes he just rides the wave he
understands this moves a team he
motivates his football team he also
understood the collection of good
players that he had especially that
defenses out of the ball and now on the
offensive side with a special player
like Nomar makes that team just go
Marcus Peters third pick six this season
I think really spurned on by my comments
here on the podcast only three players
have ever done it four times no one has
ever done five and these are the
quarterbacks that he still has up left
that he could pick six Jared Goff yes
Sam darn old yes Josh Alan Baker they
like to throw the ball to a team pick
six of all huh very interesting you know
it was good to see Hollywood Brown back
yeah see looking fast down the field I
think Mark Andrews continues to be a
unsung hero in that often he's about
catching the ball around the ball he's a
50/50 guy really take it of course you
add in there that defense and what
they're able to do I told you yesterday
I love Marlin Humphrey he's he can take
out your best receiver yes he can just
go out and say listen today you're not
getting any catches when you have that
type of defense and this is how your
defense place for your offense yeah it
allows you to be patient with that run
game even though they've been very
explosive with the run game that defense
allows you to be patient in the hard
games and the games are you saying hey
it's only six to six because our defense
is playing so we'll now Lamar doesn't
have to throw the ball 40 times even if
you're in a game that you're not leaning
looking good this is why we can't
react in the beginning of the season
when the Ravens were an absolute sieve
you know and they allowed the 33 to the
Chiefs and the 40 to the Browns and
everybody kind of got worried and then
you look what they've done since the
Browns game went to overtime with the
Steelers knocked out Mason Rudolph
allowed 23 allowed 17 to the bengals 16
at Seattle 20 to the Patriots and 13 the
bengals so since the world was
collapsing when they allowed 40 of the
Browns since then they've allowed over
21 time and it was an over game overtime
game and that's why the good the
kingsnake Kings good teams figured out
Dean Pease was not gonna allow this
defense to crumble and he's figured it
out let's go to the newly acclaimed best
segment in podcasting Monday Cup due to
the doing to the doing to do today we do
not need to do voices
thank goodness if you'd like to do a
voice you'll have to these are these are
two things they are either takes from
around the internet that in burr found
or they're interesting statistics so
it's not necessarily a believe but it's
just like things that are true that are
existing well this is a disappointing
one and this is one that hurts me to my
soul because there's always talk around
our NFL about running backs aren't worth
it and I can make the argument yesterday
the running backs were worth it the
running backs are getting it done
especially in november/december this is
when you win champions Todd Gurley
mm-hmm
did not test the ball once in the fourth
quarter there are so many questions
about this Rams team as stings where you
go okay
your offense they had a defensive
touchdown
yeah and they had a safety and I believe
they scored 12 points so they scored
three with their offense I remember a
game last year where the Rams went to
the Broncos and they was snowing
yeah and Jared Goff couldn't play
because as we've learned with Jared Goff
his road splits
he is a different quarterback he stinks
on the road all that stuff but Todd
Gurley ran for 200 yards against the
Broncos and they pulled out the win yeah
we don't have that anymore you can't
have a game or Cooper Cup where where
slot receivers have opened the Steelers
all year and then Cooper Cup has zero
catches the offensive line is a mess I
believe they had another injury
yesterday
Jared Goff is in full regression mode
right now and the defense played well I
mean the Steelers offense was crap but
like I don't even want to focus just on
Todd Gurley I just have questions about
like we were we were joking before about
the the old Dane Cook joke where he says
you know I'd break up my mic with my
boyfriend but my CDs are still in his
car there's a few of these situations
these hard conversations that like you
need to break up with these people even
if it's gonna be sometimes good and one
of those hard conversations for me is
Jared Goff oh like I know you just gave
him a hundred and whatever million but
like how do you watch a game like that
and go he's the guy you can't you can't
break up with Jared Goff yeah I know
it's it's like getting married and
buying a house and like one weekend
going around here rock top high and I
know that just hit a few people right in
the chest hurts well this is what I
think about this football team and
obviously the injury to Gurley is the
huge part and that's why everything is
going haywire because offensively before
Gurley got her list on my last year yeah
it was Todd Gurley making magic happen
Jared golf play-action pass thrown the
ball down the field yeah
these fast receivers now you don't have
that here's the thing I watched the game
yesterday 12 carries 73 yards that's 6.1
yards a carry
for Gurley there's no excuse there's no
reason not to allow him to touch the
foot ball and I was I don't understand
you said 12 yeah sake want I think had
13 yesterday um there was another big
time running back that had 8 I just
these teams sometimes get away from the
runs again there the game was close the
entire game they end up losing by 5 so
there's no reason not to give them the
football yeah there's no reason to get
away from your best player he brought 2
interceptions already but just doesn't
make any sense
listen I understand and I played with
any injuries for a long time
and there were games where I had it and
games where I didn't yesterday girly had
it
he had the stuff this is the reason what
you say when you have it you feed the
hot hand talking about the Dallas
Cowboys hello also talking about the the
st. Louis LA Rams you feed the hot hand
you allowed Todd Gurley to continue to
go off why would you not give him the
football and the one thing that shaman
bay big they said was that it was all
about the rotation well coach I believe
that you're a young genius you've done a
lot of good things in the NFL at a young
age but here's the thing
there's no rotation when you have your
best player on the bench give him the
football period especially if he's
having one of his healthier days and 112
yards 73 yards so Kerry's 73 yards you
feed that guy yeah you don't put him on
the bed and I had a conversation with
Marty morning waking I'll stop this rant
no please keep going we were I was
having a good day Marty took me out at
the goal line my first conversation as
I'm running to the sideline is you never
take out that guy that's having a great
guy a great game on the goal line you
never take the ball out of that guy's
hand because you never know this may be
the game that seals the Rams fate for
the entire season
yeah why would you do that especially
for throwing the football with Jared
golf it's disappointing if it sounds
like it felt good to get that yeah yeah
when it backs need love too so a few
other notes from this game if you want
to talk about fan bases right now that
are still feeling somewhat okay but it's
gonna get really bleak these next few
years I think one of these two
franchises is in trouble it's the Bears
and it's the Rams because there are two
teams that have mortgaged their future
they have already built their foundation
I don't think it's a foundation that you
can win Super Bowls you feel that way
don't have draft picks the Bears have
really no draft picks for next two years
cuz Leo Mac and I believe that unless
they make the adult decision in not
signing Travis no way they can stand but
like they have so much money invested
already into a few players the Rams are
the same way the Rams have no
first-round picks next year
no first-round picks in 2021 they have
this is dead cap in 2020 according to
spot track Jared Goff 51 million Todd
Gurley 25 point six million
Brandin cooks what you pay for Lamar
Jackson 20 1.8 million
Robert woods only 4.3 million but
they're so top-heavy and they have no
depth that I look at the Rams and I go
this second half of the year we talked
about the Cowboys
how much you need depth they could
really they could be really beaten up in
this second half and they're gonna need
a quarterback to be out or worldly and I
don't think that Goff has that ability
he hasn't shown it hasn't shown that he
could be that other guy that can be
specially and carry a football team he
hasn't been that guy no they need the
run game they need the pivot either have
the player and so and this is gonna
sound very unplaced unless this is a
situation that was a weird sound unless
this is a situation where Gurley is
quietly pulling a kowai and we don't
know about it where he's sort of like
doing his own load management if this is
a Rams decision I need to start asking
the Rams this question you built this
team to win now yeah I understand that
Todd Gurley zni if you go too hard right
now you might not have him in year 9 or
10 I would ask you do you think you're
gonna have him in years 9 or 10 anyway
no why not go for it and that's a very
unpleasant thing because usually we want
health and and if if his leg cannot
handle it then we need to have a much
bigger conversation but like well
through 25 carries it's Todd [ __ ]
girls well here again they're five and
four right now so there's no future for
this team if they don't start winning
some games for this season we're talking
about the postseason in a division that
you know certainly could have two teams
come out of it but you won't be that
second team if you know who the Rams
play on Sunday night this week the
[ __ ] Bears like it's two teams that
are like looking at themselves me like
this is us we need to win
bears hold on to that win over the Lions
i am i watched none of that game I had
to rewatch the clips try Biscay versus
traffic just triskele
but I I look at the Rams and I'm like
I'm worried it could all start crumbling
the only other the other other note that
I one time off in that game was
JooJoo Jalen Ramsey before the game says
he's not a B he comes out when someone
talks [ __ ] and then you get the win
that's gonna feel so good you jerk he
said he's right though I'm not a Antonio
Brown I will never be Antonio Brown I am
myself I am juju Smith Schuster I am not
as good as him yet I think I solved time
to proceed to get to his level but were
two totally different persons one
perfect answer
nailed it love is it - it's this thing
that we do in sports where we see a guy
playing in the position and they have to
be the next whatever like I'm sure the
next running backs after you in the
Eagles were we see some Ryan Westbrook
in this guy's beautiful love the I love
the way that he responded I love the way
they his outlook to the game you know
the one thing I loved and this was an
old story is that when he was in school
he reached out and telling her Brown I
mean it's just that small humbleness
because there's not a lot of guys that
are in the league now that we reach out
for help there's not a lot of guys the
college that were regional help either
and he reached out and I don't know the
a B helped a bunch ya even responded at
the time but he's humbled enough to
understand who he is who he's not but
he's also hungry he showed he's like
listen I'm still gonna grind and I still
want to achieve that I'm not there yet
yeah honest with myself those are types
of guy that you can go to war with those
are the good guys as someone that traded
for juju and fantasy in week three cuz I
was like oh they're gonna and then Ben
Roethlisberger got hurt I know that a
lot of people are going man Juju's had a
rough year and he's not a B that's a
reflection on Mason Rudolph mhm Mason
Rudolph in my mind is not a starting
quarterback in this league he is not
someone that you can build around hasn't
been great if on the Steelers I am
looking outside or I'm looking for a
trade or I'm calling up the Panthers and
saying if you're serious about this Cam
Newton stuff because we're not sure
about Big Ben coming back from injury I
don't know if that's the best
quarterback room in the in the NFL if
you're a quarterback room is Cam Newton
and Big Ben that would actually be the
worst quarterback room I want to take
back that take immediately they might
actually come to blows can you imagine
can you imagine big betting Cam Newton
walking in a pre-season and Tom and go
I'm gonna let them fight it out you're
not probably holy crap that's not
actually and now I'm rooting for it well
maybe Mason true Tom Hart knock
it's better with
time maybe because bids coming back
he'll be assuming the business run off
no come on you can't use I'll say this
you can't do that today you make the big
Internet conversation right now is
people going why are we being so hard on
Kyle Allen of Carolina like we're giving
more props to Mason Rudolph and like I
see plays out of Kyle Allen once a week
where I go that's a good play or lose
the ball he escapes and makes a good
play and and it's a little heady I know
that there's some Panthers Twitter that
are saying that he goes to his first
read too much I have not seen I see the
occasional deep ball for Mason Rudolph
where I go not bad mm-hmm but I don't
see it it takes some time for young
quarterbacks like I saw in the gridiron
thing people go and it's been a roller
coaster ride for Kyler Murray this year
and I go it's supposed to all I want to
see out of my rookies is the highs okay
because you're showing me what you're
capable of every rookie is going to have
the lows but I need this roller coaster
to be like steel force at Dorney Park
right where it gets super [ __ ] high
because Nats you know I mean like we saw
sparks from deshaun Watson to know that
he could build when the ruin the Ravens
went on a six-game winning streak with
Lamar we saw what he could do now he's
even exceeded mom's we saw what he could
do right I have not seen any of the
highs for Mason Rudolph that make me
think that once we get rid of the lows
Hobie here's the highs they've won four
games in a row that's that's the highs
and I would argue that it's it's BM and
AM it's before Minka and it's after mica
it's in the cup yeah so the Steelers
were oh and two before Minka they're
five and two after Menken offenses
played much better they've been
incredible incredible and that was
actually the point that I was going to
get to before Pat Pat called which was
the turnovers wow I was able to bring it
all back by game Pittsburgh Steelers
defense game by game okay turnovers kind
of remind times sacked for against the
Rams five against the Colts four against
the Dolphins only one against the
Chargers five against the Baltimore
Ravens eight against the Bengals that's
sacs interceptions three against the
Rams so three one two two three those
are in
perception yes that's five six eight
that's 11 in the last five weeks some
teams don't get 11 for the whole year
fumbles forced four for three so the
last three weeks they have forced six
interceptions and 11 fumbles yes that's
their play not about they're playing
good defensively mica looks great Joe
Hayden I think had five pass deflections
last night because he's got a good core
around him but Dupree and TJ Watkins
come getting word what about I the
Steelers are doing it all defense right
now
loving it that's good like with my
team's that's how the Steelers made
their name package a defensive football
nasty physical they got a bunch of young
guys on this defense that's why they're
known as the Iron Curtain and they're
nasty and they're physical and they get
after it and don't let them get a lead
they're gonna they're gonna jump or the
Steel Curtain I was [ __ ] around in
the next three weeks at Cleveland what
did you call it Iron Curtain there's a
joke at Cleveland at Bengals at
Cleveland like it I mean the Steelers
could be eight and four should we also
be make it Arizona then they get the
Jets in they end with Baltimore so
that's should we also simultaneously be
a Steelers podcast and predict that
they're gonna go like nine and four in
their next four should should we get
both fan bases we should they have a
Cleveland Cinci Cleveland era ya know
they're getting too much love as it is I
think we're too late I think we missed
it
they've won four in a row we probably do
know I think we should actually go the
opposite I think we should say that the
Steelers came off the by was struggling
against the Dolphins at home down 14
nothing came back had to get their
injured quarterback Brian Hoyer against
the Colts to eke out a win and Adam
Vinatieri missed a game-winning field
goal and then they take on the Rams and
they get like a defensive touchdown and
their offense looks like crap I actually
think we should go the opposite and say
oh by the way Steelers all three of
those last wins were at home and of your
last one two three four five six seven
games five of them are road games I
actually think we should look at
Steelers fans and say here comes in
pending doom
gonna lose a really disappointing game
and you might be the Bengals first win
of the season no they will happen with
that maven to you they will not be the
Bengals verse what about that would be
Kirk cost is the buff you just watched
me build a take live I like that I like
I like the way you did that I will be
cautious from the Steelers heading into
Cleveland next week little look it's
there it's this Thursday that's right
Thursday yeah a little momentum short
week you're traveling small grounds got
momentum just a little bit just enough
Thursday so I figure it out Carolina
game going with Nick Chubb hey coming
hunt out of the backfield looking good
catching the football he did and also
you look at the Browns and what they
their defense look they allowed 16
points to Buffalo huh it was a 75 yard
touchdown for Noah fan that kept it from
it's 24 points they weren't really that
bad against the Patriots 27 of the 27
for the Patriots was a fumble recovery
this is the most important defense gets
gonna shut down they salute this is how
this is why the Browns won this get this
game this little past week against the
bills because they normally shoot
themselves in the foot penalties here
and they're all over the place they won
this game because they have three
penalties that's why they play
discipline football they don't throw the
ball to the other team off duty and they
got their running game called NICTA
that's one of my other teams that needs
to have the talk really yeah they have
to have to talk with Freddie kitchen
sorry bro you're not coming back I don't
care if you were in the last six games
you're not coming back
alright we only did one cup so where we
gonna be quicker this is from Tom -
Angelo 44 dolphins are three games out
of a wild-card spot love it that's Gary
the doorman downstairs said I'm angry at
my dolphins because they keep winning
games and I said to him things are going
a the best way they could if you're a
Dolphins fan from this regard this
dolphins tank has shown us that there is
no player on this team that they really
want to build around that's right none
they are starting from the ground up
which means there is only one person you
are building around and that is your
head coach Brian Flores everybody is
disposable but you need to see if he's
the guy
and now in the last few weeks to have
back-to-back wins but really if you look
at the Dolphins they have been
competitive for a number of weeks ahead
they were up 14 nothing over the
Steelers and then the bottom fell out
they were they had a lead over the bills
in the second half and they lost that
game they lost 17 is 16 to the
Washington Redskins but let's be honest
Ryan Fitzpatrick came in the game this
is all post Josh Rosen this team is
fighting and so the number one thing you
needed in a tank is to know you got the
right guy at the helm and I am an expert
in tanking because I am a Philadelphia
76ers fan I dealt with all the [ __ ]
for all those years and I trusted the
process and now my team has a chance to
win a title and I'll say this a lot of
people are going oh no the Bengals are
gonna get the first pick or here come
the Giants the Dolphins got to stop
winning the most important part of the
process for the Sixers is and beat it is
not Simmons Simmons was a first pick and
beed was the third because he's hurt
just because you have the first pick
that's not just the reason that you're
tanking it's you have to make the right
pick mahomes and Watson went after a
true Biscay they are they are they have
amassed a ton of draft picks they are
finding out who on this team you can
build around they are resting their
players that they actually want to build
around that they do have one their
cornerback he's their only guy that they
want to keep save Ian Howard but most
importantly I believe that the Dolphins
have found their coach I know they went
in it was Brian Hoyer and Paris Campbell
and to you by Hilton didn't play but
this is a team now for five weeks in a
row has fought and now two weeks in a
row has won and I look at the Dolphins
and I say I believe that they're they're
tanking their process is going maybe
better than they then then we gave him
credit for because when you look at the
three teams that they lost to in the
beginning of the year when it was
embarrassing
it was the ravens it was the Patriots it
was the Cowboys and they were beating
the Cowboys at halftime
yeah choose all I'm just saying top
things you're right about [ __ ] go
it's not about the first pick you're
absolutely right about that because
wherever you pick in the top five you're
gonna get a quality player and that's
what this team they just need playmakers
chasing Tatum one third Markel full 21
they got a bunch of guys Michael Jordan
most importantly poor great water so
there's that but I think right hand yeah
no here's a deal that you're right about
the coach in when you have a coach most
important thing that you got to do early
on is get rid of all the guys aren't
willing to fight for you now all the
guys are going to walk out the dirt door
earlier in the season get rid of all of
them every like I don't care if you
install Sunday and we're not even mad at
them no because I get it you don't wanna
be here get rid of every last one of
them yeah the other thing you have to do
is establish character in culture this
team was only fighting them there are
two terrible football team there without
a two and seven the only reason they're
fighting is because of their coach
because he said listen guys some of you
guys gonna be here next next year some
of you aren't somebody gonna be looking
for another place to play but the guys
that are here we're gonna win some
football games and we when we win and
nobody expects us to win it's gonna be a
miracle and everybody's gonna be jumping
on them the Dolphins bandwagon that's
gonna be special you had the right guy
as a head coach because these guys
continue to fight this is easy to walk
out to the field when you're terrible
and just lose yes
find a reason to lose okay oh they're
winning that half telling us just lose
yes these guys continue to fight you're
absolutely right
I bought it on Brian Flores toward one
of the whoa big off seasons where he had
a huge mural painted outside the
practice field that said TNT and every
time a snap was fumbled a penalty what
happened the whole team had to run and
touch the wall because TNT stood for
takes no talent and they got punished
every time they did something that took
no talent Brian Flores is already in my
top five yelling at the referee rant
face guys he throws headsets he gets
angry with his fanny pack when they had
that awful call in the Steelers game
where they measure the fourth and one oh
he tore into him yesterday they call off
a play to bring Ryan Fitzpatrick into
the blue tent to check him for a
concussion and Brian Flores was like a
manager
an 80s kicking dirt on the referee
spitting in his face calling his mama
name's Brian Flores is already there was
a we I put up for the podcast who should
be their favorite coach of the podcast
and it ended up being Sean McVeigh but
Brian Flores was the one where I was
like I kind of wanted to be him or
Fangio will you get him we could make
this right now Brian Flores podcast you
get them a little talent and they've
gonna get that because of Tunsil pick me
the trade yes they're gonna get a bunch
of talent and it's on to this football
team they find themself a quarterback at
some point Ryan Fitzpatrick is not that
guy see the best though Ryan is great
because he's like you know what I'm just
gonna throw the ball and that's what I
do and we're gonna have fun with it and
I'll win you a bunch of games and that
beard is out of control
Ryan Fitzpatrick is the guy that he just
hangs around and always has a good time
and also I'm the voice of him and
gridiron Heights are you so I love when
love if I love the fact that I feel like
you to Harvard yeah I mean he's smart he
gets it done but he also more
importantly than that and I like guys
that are smart engage Ryan Fitzpatrick
right now it has also reached an
incredible level of having averaging a
double-double in terms of references
that get made when he plays so you know
that when you which watch Ryan
Fitzpatrick that he's going to be a
Harvard grad that will be mentioned but
also they have to mention his age
because now it's 36 year old yeah Ryan
Fitzpatrick so I feel like Ryan
Fitzpatrick is one information nugget
away from the rare mandatory triple
reference we don't see that a lot you
don't know how long he has a triple
reference but the beard is the other one
yeah it's in a beard every time yeah
it's every time it's luscious it's out
of control
how does he put his chin strap on there
are times I don't know that wears chin
is that a like does he just sweat
constantly at cancer I have never had
facial hair to know what it's like to
have that the beard can't smell good I
mean it has to smell pretty what would
it be like eating a been a messy any any
food item powdered Donuts how about that
really beignet is just a high-class
powdered doughnut sure did you know what
beignet was I dunno went to New Orleans
before you're a recent trip I appreciate
that was good this is from Jake
underscore Trotter uh-huh
the Browns now have the easiest
remaining schedule in the NFL how about
that and that is why I think the Browns
need to have the uncomfortable talk in
the in them in their front office right
now don't want him to keep winning games
so everybody think I said this on with
Nick Wright on the radio a few weeks ago
he said what's the percentage chance
that Freddie kitchen is back to coach
week-10 200 and I said a hundred and he
was floored and I said because the
Browns after the Titans game or after
the the Bills game it turns into the
easiest schedule in the NFL it's
dolphins
it's bengals twice it's Cardinals hold
on let me finish the question
Oh before you keep going I just think
they need to go guys even if we win four
of seven and you're like oh look we're
getting better be realistic about who
you're playing who are you having to
talk with though who do they're gonna
call in John Dorsey needs to be there
with the owner and they need to go which
we believe that Freddie kitchens is the
guy
I don't think so can he make the
quarterback better that's the only
question can Freddie kitchens make their
quarterback there was more on that and
better yeah there's more okay listen
the Browns now have the easiest
remaining schedule in the NFL according
to ESPN football power index ESPN also
now gives the Browns a ten point nine
percent chance of making the playoffs
following Sunday's win I will say this
though if they make the playoffs
I still think you let them go no they
can't make the playoff can they they yes
they can't if they tell you they beat
the Steelers on Thursday night they go
to four and six you got two games
against the Bengals let's chalk them up
that's six and six Miami let's say Ryan
Fitzpatrick doesn't go crazy that seven
in sinks so now you have two game you
have one more game against Pittsburgh
Cardinals that could be a win let's say
that's eight and six you got a you know
you got a steal the Raiders are still
available for use the Colts envoy of
some point get per setback wildcard
and I'm still I mean I like the Jaguars
I would feel more comfortable with the
Steelers then the Browns of course I'm
just saying there is a chance you may
have another game with low penalties I
don't know I don't know but I think that
the Browns the schedule certainly has is
going to put them in a position where
they have an opportunity to win these
games the question is will they would
they hurt themselves enough in these
games to lose that's the big question
the Browns had I believe at one point
eight plays in a row inside of with gold
to go and got zero yards yeah and my
issue with Freddie kitchens is he goes
for it when he shouldn't he kicks it
when he shouldn't end games it's all
over the place I don't like their play
calling I just I don't think he's the
guy here's a question if you're if
you're Freddie kitchens you got Baker
Jarvis Odell Beckham jr. hunt and Chubb
what's your first option with that
offensive line I'm probably finding ways
to move Odell around okay that's
probably that's the floor thought
process and I think that's what Freddie
kid says wants to do you got to run the
ball first because Nick Chubb has been
your best and most consistent player all
season long but they want to continue to
put the ball in Baker's hands so he can
win the game with Jarvis in the guy I
just had this conversation with [ __ ]
sharp so much about like the personnel
they use and we'll see but like for me
you can have an offense with two tight
ends two wide receivers and Nick Chubb
out there yeah you can have it just be
Odell and Jarvis yes put a little bit of
a heavy formation and use play-action
absolutely and still get Chubb the ball
but like I need them I don't see any
formational creativity unless it's like
hey we need a two-point conversion
here's four wide receivers on one side
of the field I don't see any motion well
he was an innovative play caller the
reason he came in last year he was know
what it was nobody knew B nobody knew
what he was he wasn't a running back
coach that got the offensive coordinator
job everybody just getting he's the guy
may this is from JA jzz early the Kansas
City Chiefs have lost in their last 13
losses including the playoffs have lost
by seven points or less the longest
streak in the NFL history in the NFL
history
I'm concerned about Kansas City I'm not
uh here's what's another heartache
here's what I'm concerned going into the
season
you knew that Pat mahomes is gonna be
that guy it he is he's the continues
right but when he's still special like
he was yesterday and you still lose that
concerns me yeah that puts you in the
spot where you like hollowed out time
out we know that he's gonna be special
because he's been special so many times
before and he was special yesterday but
you still lose yeah
you still put art in a position to lose
and that defense continues it gets
shredded in the run game
november/december can't you run the
football and can't you stop the run and
they can't stop the run they ran the
ball well yesterday with Williams he ran
the ball well he looks fast
he looks at Lou civ or whatever they do
well you got to be able to stop the damn
run no he had that [ __ ] sloppiness
fumble were hurt not about so my thing
is is when you look at that game and you
go Titans got a defensive touchdown on a
return yeah the Chiefs blew a field goal
attempt at the end to make it an eight
point lead and then got an intentional
grounding by the holder which I've never
seen before
and then had a field goal blocked to end
the game so even with all that [ __ ] they
were still right there on the road but I
would agree with you them in the close
ones I think the scariest thing is for
the Chiefs perspective we've already
seen deshaun Watson go into Kansas City
and dice you up the Ravens can run the
ball better than almost anybody and
that's your Achilles heel the Patriots
are gonna be we'll see how they handle
in a few weeks
the Chiefs do look beatable but I also
because they were the one seed last year
we have expectations they could also be
the scariest [ __ ] four seed in the
tournament
yeah and so my thing about the cheese is
it's how you look at them they are not
gonna be the home field advantage team
but at the same point they're four and
one on the road
this is a team that offense travels so I
look at the Chiefs not from the
perspective of oh wow they're not gonna
be the Superbowl favorite fine
you let mahomes get into that tournament
y'all are on notice because no team is
scarier than them and so that's how I'm
looking at from the other that class
yeah you're looking at that way I'm
looking
at their defense missing tackles Ryan
Tannehill running over safeties not
looking physical bro they looked they
looked Wan Thornhill's [ __ ] fun
inspire to boy this is the brand new
defense acquit it's a different guy
Spagnola wasn't there last year so this
is I like I like swags but this defense
just doesn't look very good at this
point most importantly you're up at the
end of the game you give the ball over
to Tannehill and the Titans and they go
for plays 61 yards to win the football
game with the number one free agent
signing Adam Humphries this the middle
mahomes leaves the field with the lead
win the football game they go and have
this drive and I don't know how long the
drive was don't think you just said it
yeah he's 58 seconds that's what it was
and it was tan hell running over people
throwing skinny stuff just get hurt
Henry where's the pressure Chris Jones
looked great yesterday early on all I'm
gonna say is this about the Chiefs it's
Trouble Man
they they lose to the Colts in a 19-13
game or Patrick mahomes was on the
sideline for like 40 minutes yeah run
control texans up and back battle but if
you remember right texans got a fumble
with like 5 seconds left in the first
half inside the cheese 5 to get an extra
like it's been a lot of self-inflicted
stuff packers there in that game that
was with Matt Moore you know and then
this Titans came so like the Chiefs are
in but then again and you look at their
wins and their wins are kind of hairy
too yes but I love the Chiefs I think
that they're still the most entertaining
team to watch on Sunday let the Titans
put up 35 freakin points on them yeah
remember defensive touchdown all that
yeah
Marshawn Lattimore suffered a hamstring
strain that's week to week as soon as he
left the game Julio and off yeah the
Saints are the one team that I actually
am actually worried about are you like
of all the the big teams that lost
yesterday with like the Cowboys I know I
just called him over right and all that
the Saints were the one where I was like
what the [ __ ] was that where it's like
they came out of the bye and the Falcons
were like get the Falcons got six sacks
on Drew Brees
yes that's a problem this I believe the
Falcons had seven sacks
season Brian that's a problem that's
brand and if Marshawn Latimore's about
to be week-to-week and he's one of the
best corn he's a top five corner in this
game and I'm watching camara look
hobbled and I'm looking at Drew Brees
not able to get the ball deep that was a
[Music]
something stinking and I'm worried that
it's a fire I will remind you I told you
this at the beginning of the show you
need the Pope to tweet there is a you
told me about them to the pope they're
gonna win so now you're off the baler no
no I mean you have to be able to win in
November and December the things you
have to do is run the football and stop
the run yesterday they couldn't run the
football and they couldn't I mean this
is the same thing team after team at the
team they couldn't stop the run I'm not
as worried about the Saints though and
here's the reason why I believe in your
breeze
I believe in Sean Payton Camaro is gonna
get healthy I'm wondering I've been
wondering this for a couple weeks now
Kim latavius Mary in Alva camara be the
same as Mark Ingram and camel takers
Mary say okay I'm only gonna get ten
care he made this u s-- made this point
yesterday that was a great point that
Ingram is a guy that can get in the game
and punch you right in the mouth and
doesn't need a lot of carries where
latavius Cana needs to carry in 25 times
yeah and they're big games we he's got
eight and nine carries he has some
decent yards he catches the ball
decently out of the backfield I'm just
wondering how effective can that offers
be without the thunder and lightning
aspect to it with with latavius Murray
not getting as many carrier latavius
Murray is more of a Brandon Jenna yes he
needs to get up 30 shots he has to get
the shots up he's not uh who is the
microwave that was on the Sacramento
Kings small guard back in the knees
Vinny Jambi Jackson was it was it like
he was the guy that like you put on the
floor and you're like twelve points go
three minutes you know the thing that I
watched the Saints and I'm watching it
yeah yeah and I'm saying Drew Brees is
at the bak back of his dropped the top
of his drop and ready to throw the
football and has nobody to throw through
no the six sacks that's what they all
came sits [ __ ] liked Raekwon Smith do
they do they have this power power
powerful down the field target are
though
no I think we're missing I think you're
you're looking at the pedals and you're
you're not looking at the infected route
well you look which is true breezes and
ability to throw them all over 35 yards
I had 12 penalties yesterday to have
some issue think they had four hands to
the face panel yeah they had 12 in total
here's the other thing I think this was
the aberration about his things they
overlooked the falcons coming off of us
about over by one of those things
division game which are always tough
yeah but guess what you better not [ __ ]
up anymore because the Saints don't have
a buy right now no San Francisco's the
one Green Bay is the - okay so let's say
the Saints beat the Vikings you know
where they're going in that second round
of the divisional round playoffs Lambeau
okay you know who I'm betting against
Drew Brees in Green Bay Wisconsin in
January to go that looks like a hundred
and fifty five yards one touchdown two
interceptions and a lost fumble it's a
bucket all right last one because we've
already gone about a matter in 15 the
NFC West has a combined record of 23 12
and one okay the NFC East is 13 and 24 I
believe that the NFC East is the worst
division in football top to bottom they
have the worst division leader I think
they have the Eagles are like yeah
whatever well I think they are the the
were the Giants and yashuna terrible
teams in that division yeah and we're
still trying to figure out what the
Cowboys and really quite honestly what
the Eagles are so you're figuring out
what the best teams are in the do you
have two of the worst teams in football
he went back and looked at my Vegas
tickets and I forgot one of mine was
Eagles to win the division and that went
up big-time yesterday I think you got a
thank you Vikings well that's gonna come
down for the Eagles and Cowboys who can
who wins their final game that's what it
is
and who consider week 17 think it's week
16 because I think the Eagles have
Washington last game of the season so I
mean it's just gonna come down to that
who gets better over that time period
it's gonna be cold in week 16 at home
against the Eagles for 25 that's got
Jill and Troy a look at hey Matt you're
getting blown out the first game
absolutely first time they maxed each
other coming off a three-game stretch of
dolphins Giants Washington
is gonna be ready they better be ready
they got a tough test this week I've
never rooted for the team that was nine
and seven but won the division and
probably like kept out like a really
good team I'm excited to root for a team
like that get yourself everyone's like
they should restock it by conference do
not look at the David deal Giants what
if they're that team that team that just
nobody expected myself they just get hot
at the right time to do it but i'ma do
it oh how do you do that go beat the
Patriots get hot now
go beat them don't get me excited a man
get hot now if we beat the Patriots I'm
gonna be this is the time to be talking
I'm gonna come up with so many rants
about how they're gonna win the service
is the time to do it my brother yeah
Patriots Seahawks if you could be both
of those teams no Sh at home now you're
now we're tough 16 to know they're going
sixteen there's never a losing ship cuz
you got the Redskins you'll beat the
Cowboys and you know I heard that if
they beat the Patriots and Seahawks all
the losses from earlier in the schedule
vanish vanish
yeah they disappear quickly also no more
games on turf alright oh yeah exactly
love it um Westberg it was fun watching
games with unit giant that's a turf game
oh yeah they have turf it's not indoors
though yeah
always a pleasure I don't know what
we're doing for Wednesday yet I can't
think that far ahead
ping BRR pat pat cup awesome stuff and
then also Bengal Dolphin giant tank is
always blessed you're the [ __ ] man
poor Brian Westbrook the rock you man
happy happy happy Veterans Day all the
veterans out there appreciate ya we
salute your service love you guys i am
the LEF koe man we'll holler at you next
week or later this week [ __ ] later
this week bye love you bye
[Music]